les gilets jaunes vont-ils réussir leur
rentrée sur les réseaux sociaux il
semble en tout cas prêt à redescendre
dans les rues
puisque des appels à manifester ont été
lancés un peu partout en france
à paris quatre manifestations sont
prévues pour la première le rendez vous
est donné à 9 heures sur les champs
elysées est la deuxième ce sera 10
heures place de la bourse mais meurt
pour la troisième en revanche ça sera
place wagram la quatrième à 13 heures
place saint pierre et sur ces quatre
manifestations
trois sont d'ores et déjà interdite aux
vues je cite des risques des troubles à
l'ordre public
le préfet de police a interdit les
rassemblements se revendiquant du
mouvement des gilet jaune à compter du
vendredi 11 septembre à 18 heures dans
plusieurs secteurs de la capitale ainsi
que deux manifestations ce samedi 12
septembre
parmi les secteurs concernés par ces
interdictions figurent notamment lé
champs elysées l'assemblée nationale
matignon la préfecture de police ou
encore le champ de mars
mais qu'importe l'interdiction certains
gilet jaune veulent un retour aux
sources s'est manifesté là où tout a
commencé sur les champs elysées
j'appelle à une désobéissance civile
complète
je vous invite ce jour là à ne montrer
aucune carte d'identité quitte à aller
faire un petit tour au commissariat pour
une vérité entités et qui passé quatre
heures entre en perdre un oeil et les
faire chier appliquer la désobéissance
civile hashtag désobéissance poursuit un
appel à la désobéissance civile qui est
loin de faire l'unanimité et qui suscite
même la moquerie d'autres leaders du
mouvement où les avait prévenus de votre
évolution
elle est bien au chaud
on s'assoit on campe tu t'en es ma team
au commissariat le fait d'écrire à demi
tour avec le sandwich on va te l'envoyer
au comico c'est pas grave qui reste
quatre heures et la révolution espace au
commissariat ouais
ces dissensions persistent depuis des
mois et elle ont peut-être même pesé
dans l'essoufflement du mouvement des
gilet jaune
quoi qu'il en soit tout l'enjeu de ce 12
septembre c'est d'évaluer si un nouveau
souffle est encore possible
l exécutif craint un retour de flamme et
pour cause la gestion du gouvernement de
la crise sanitaire a amplifié la colère
sociale
on dit qu'il ya la seconde vague du coc
vide
il va y avoir la seconde vague gilet
jaune de hashtag de septembre et ouais
c'est une date très importante ça va
montrer le mécontentement de la
population
comme on peut le voir en ce moment c'est
délicat dans notre pays la rentrée sera
quand même très très très revendicatif
il ya des préoccupations qu'attendent
les français aujourd'hui c'est comment
vivre dignement et on avait toujours
demandé qu' un grenelle du poids d'achat
qu'ils soient faits en bois un grenelle
3 d'achat économiques et fiscales qui
sont organisées par l'état pour savoir
si aujourd'hui avec son salaire on peut
vivre dignement la démission des manuels
macron est toujours réclamé tout comme
les demandes pour plus de justice
sociale fiscales et environnementales
dans le détail les gilet jaune réclame
300 euros de plus pour les bas salaires
les retraites et les aides sociales
l'essence à 1 euro ou encore la
libération de plus de 800 manifestants
qualifié de prisonniers politiques